[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOANNA SMITH: Welcome back
to the showroom floor, y'all.
I'm really excited to
be here, because now I'm
over in the customer magic zone,
and it's really, really cool.
But right now, I'm
standing with Claes,
who is a senior
engineer for Ikea,
and he's going to show
us one of the most
popular demos in the area.
There are crowds of
people trying to fight
their way in right now.
Hey, back up.
I'm looking at you.
So before you actually
show me how it works,
can you tell me a
little bit about how
your team developed this?
CLAES ADAMSSON: Yeah, sure.
So we assembled a pretty
small team that we can work
in an iterative fashion-
JOANNA SMITH: Nice.
CLAES ADAMSSON:
--dividing the work,
but close feedback
loops together
with Google engineering.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, cool!
CLAES ADAMSSON:
Yeah, and we used
the Vision API, product search.
JOANNA SMITH: The
Cloud Vision API?
CLAES ADAMSSON: Yes.
JOANNA SMITH: I love that.
CLAES ADAMSSON:
Yeah, it's awesome.
Together with object detection
that we're trying out together
with Google--
JOANNA SMITH: Nice.
CLAES ADAMSSON: --yeah, to
enhance the product offering
from your side and also try
to work with the customer
experience on our side.
So you'll see in the demo.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
And then you talked about
how your team really
focused on working iteratively.
Now, I heard a rumor that y'all
did this whole thing in less
than three weeks.
Is that true?
CLAES ADAMSSON: Yeah,
it's pretty amazing.
Yeah, yeah--
JOANNA SMITH: Oh my gosh!
CLAES ADAMSSON:
--we're fast-paced.
Very short sprints that we did.
JOANNA SMITH: So you
got to work with--
you mentioned some
Google engineers,
which is really cool.
But you also-- you get to
work for a company that really
encourages and gives you the
space to try these ideas so
quickly like that.
How does that feel
as a developer?
CLAES ADAMSSON:
That's really good
that we are empowered to do
these kind of exploration
cases.
JOANNA SMITH: It sounds
like a dream, right?
CLAES ADAMSSON:
Yeah, it really is.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, so
speaking of dreams, will you
show me how this works, maybe
on the horse right there?
CLAES ADAMSSON:
Yeah, sure, sure.
So this is, here we try
to detect the object.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, that's cool!
CLAES ADAMSSON: Yeah?
And then it matches--
JOANNA SMITH: And
then it matches it.
CLAES ADAMSSON: --to our range.
Right.
And then you can
interact with it.
And it will show you our
mobile web page, where you--
JOANNA SMITH: Nice!
CLAES ADAMSSON: --could
get more information.
JOANNA SMITH: And then
could you do this stool?
CLAES ADAMSSON: Yeah, for sure.
So let's try it out.
It will recognize it,
and show directly it's
a [INAUDIBLE] stool.
And then we can move over here.
JOANNA SMITH: Ooh.
I like this.
CLAES ADAMSSON: And
you can interact.
JOANNA SMITH: So
the idea is that
instead of taking
that little pencil,
you can walk around and--
CLAES ADAMSSON: Yeah, exactly.
JOANNA SMITH: --build
your list with your phone?
CLAES ADAMSSON: Yeah,
point and click.
JOANNA SMITH: Does it
even get decorative items?
CLAES ADAMSSON: Of
course, of course.
So let's try this one out.
So you see here,
it got it directly.
JOANNA SMITH: This is so cheap.
And it's a plant I can't
kill, because it's fake.
CLAES ADAMSSON: It's
even called faka.
JOANNA SMITH: Really?
CLAES ADAMSSON: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Is that the--
CLAES ADAMSSON: It's Swedish.
JOANNA SMITH: For fake?
CLAES ADAMSSON: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh my gosh!
I want one so badly.
This is a really cool demo.
CLAES ADAMSSON: Thanks.
JOANNA SMITH: I
understand now why
there's a crowd of people
waiting to get back in here.
CLAES ADAMSSON: [INAUDIBLE]
JOANNA SMITH: So I want to thank
you so much for talking to me--
CLAES ADAMSSON: And thank you.
JOANNA SMITH: --and
for building this.
CLAES ADAMSSON: Thanks
for having us here.
JOANNA SMITH: I'm so excited.
I will be in the
store pretty soon.
CLAES ADAMSSON: You're welcome.
JOANNA SMITH: Have a great day.
CLAES ADAMSSON: Yeah, likewise.
JOANNA SMITH: And then thanks
to all of y'all for watching.
And we'll show you some
more cool things later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]